avec franis depuis 3 ans il ne se quitte
plus François Fillon exministre débarqué
du gouvernement rafarin fait aujourd'hui
figure de favori pour matigon même s'il
s'en défend- que vous vous préparez à
exercer cette fonction non non vous
pouvez me poser la question dans tous
les sens vous aurez
pas non c'est pas je me prépare pas
c'est
que il faut pas qu'on mélange les étapes
autre hypothèse mais cette fois moins
probable Jean-Louis borleau 15 ministres
une promesse de parité égale forte
concurrence à l'heure du choix il y a
les anciens Michel aliarie Alain Jup et
peut-être aussi Michel Barnier circul
les noms des fidèles comme brissortefeu
ou Patrick
devan parmi les jeunes qui montent
Xavier Bertrand Rachida Dati ancien
porte-parole pendant la campagne les
secrétaires d'État seront nommés après
les législatives et pourrait compter
Valéri P
ieus morcolas SAR veut une ouverture
centre il s'intéresse aux UDF Maurice
Leroi ou Christian Blanc et vers la
gauche au socialiste Jean-Marie bequel
depuis ce matin un nouvel homme accepte
bien volontiers d'entrer à l'Élysée
Claude Guéant ancien directeur de
cabinet de Nicolas Sarkozi serait très
heureux de devenir le secrétaire général
il pourrait ainsi rester dans l'ombre de
son patron devenu
président